demander le lendemain de ses émeutes de
pouvoir faire que les préfets sur tout
le territoire national empêche la
construction la constitution de cocktail
Molotov et donc ne vendent plus de
l'essence en bidon dans les stations
essence la difficulté évidemment c'est
que l'essence est parfois récupéré
directement des voitures et donc ça
limite la portée mais enfin c'était
quand même déjà assez et c'est efficace
et interdise la vente c'est pour ça que
les fermetures administratives de
magasins dans vos territoires le
contrôle au douanes et j'en remercie
mystère des grands publics pour les
venus à l'étranger je pense notamment
vers l'Allemagne la Belgique qui permet
d'acheter plus facilement des mortiers
mais également dans les tirs dans les
contrôles de pardon de relais postaux et
de colis puisque des commandes sont
faites illégalement sur Internet ou de
transport de mortier vous avez vu par
exemple une affaire puisque la
préjudiciaire suit désormais
particulièrement ces filières il n'y a
pas d'autres mots nous avons fait par
exemple 300 kg à Porte de Clignancourt
ce matin ou hier soir je ne sais plus
qui montre l'efficacité des services de
pêche judiciaires il est évident qu'une
partie des mortiers était stockée pour
la nuit du 13 au 14 juillet et peut-être
a été anticipé comme marbe par
destination je pense d'ailleurs à des
élus qui ont été le fait de s'étire dans
la maire de Pontoise qui a été brûlé du
fait de notre sœur de mortier par
exemple chacun a pu le const